- [scatting]
HEY, LIZ, WHAT'S UP?
- I'M JUST GETTING STARTED
ON, LIKE, AN AMAZINGLY
SCATHING EMAIL.
I'M SO ANGRY ALL THE TIME,
AND I FIND, LIKE, EMAIL'S,
LIKE, A REALLY GOOD PLACE
TO TAKE OUT THAT ANGER
AND SORT OF, LIKE,
IN A LOGICAL, VERY FIERY WAY.
- [belches]
- OH, MY GOD.
ARE YOU OKAY?
- LIZ.
- WHAT?
- I'M PREGNANT.
- WAIT.
WHAT?
PREGNANT?
- THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME
I'VE TOLD LIZ
ABOUT MY PREGNANCY.
BUT, LIKE, YOU'RE CARRYING
THIS ONE TO TERM?
- I DECIDED TO KEEP THIS ONE.
LIKE, I KNOW MANY OTHERS
HAVE FALLEN AWAY.
- FIRST OFF, I FEEL, LIKE,
BLINDSIDED BY THIS.
LIKE, SECOND OF ALL...
- HOW DARE YOU?
- LIKE, CONGRATULATIONS.
- THANK YOU.
- YOU'RE WELCOME.
[slurping]
- UM, JUST ONE QUICK--
- CASSANDRA, JUST WAIT
FOR, LIKE, A NATURAL LULL
IN THE CONVERSATION.
[slurping]
- SO I REALLY LOVED
WORKING HERE.
- OBVI.
- BUT THE TIME HAS COME
FOR ME TO MOVE ON.
BUT DON'T WORRY, I AM NOT GONNA
LEAVE YOU GUYS IN THE LURCH.
I'VE ALREADY FOUND
MY REPLACEMENT.
I'M GONNA TRAIN HIM
REALLY, REALLY WELL
SO THAT NO BUSINESS
IS INTERRUPTED IN ANY WAY.
- LIKE, HONESTLY, CASSANDRA,
LIKE, AND I'M, LIKE,
AN OPEN, KIND SPIRIT,
AND, LIKE, I DON'T
HOLD A GRUDGE.
SO I JUST WANNA SAY, LIKE,
I'M SO HAPPY FOR YOU
THAT YOU'RE, LIKE,
TAKING TIME TO, LIKE,
GO OUT THERE
AND, LIKE, DO NOTHING
AND, LIKE,
TRY AND FIND YOURSELF
AND JUST, LIKE, FIND OUT
IF YOUR PERSONALITY IS.
- ♪ WE'RE A TEAM
- I GOT MY OWN REALITY SHOW.
- WHAT?
- IT'S ABOUT ME
AND MY FAMILY.
- WHAT?
- [belches]
- LIZ, HOW DOES YOUR BACK
FEEL RIGHT NOW?
- YOU KNOW WHAT,
ACTUALLY, LIKE,
MY BACK HURTS ME A BIT BECAUSE
I'M PREGNANT, FIRST OF ALL.
- WAIT, WHAT?
- I'M HAVING A BABY.
- ANYTHING
THAT MAKES ME QUESTION
MY OWN PLACE
IN MY OWN LIFE,
I BLACK IT OUT.
LIZ MIGHT BE PREGNANT
WITH A BABY RIGHT NOW,
BUT I AM PREGNANT
WITH FURIOSITY, OKAY?
AND I AM NOT TAKING EPIDURAL,
'CAUSE I WANNA FEEL
EVERYTHING.